- Supposedly, a car is gonna meet us here,
a truck is gonna meet us here.
- [Passenger] Yeah, it
must be these dudes.
- You think so?
- [Passenger] They're
goin' so slow through here.
- [Dr. Mike] Is this them?
(white noise whooshes)
(minimal music)
- So they say look, you
can consider working,
even if you've been exposed,
as long as you have a mask,
and by the way, we don't
necessarily have enough masks,
so within those guidelines
as well, they say,
bandanas and scarves could
potentially be considered
to be used as well.
- Use scarves and bandanas?
I'm not gonna let my friends
that're working on the front
lines, nurses, doctors, CMAs,
that're seeing, treating
patients, to go and get scarves
and hope that that somehow
protects them from this virus.
I'm gonna do what I can.
What I can is getting these masks.
(record scratches)
Yes, I'm gonna take
to the streets in just a moment,
but first, what masks am I talking about?
I'm talking about N95 masks.
Not these, not these, these.
Why do I want these?
Long story short, N95 masks
protect medical workers
by filtering out at least 95%
of particulates in the air.
They fit very close to the face
and actually need to
be fit-tested by staff,
as opposed to surgical
masks, which hang loose
and don't provide nearly
the same protection.
Okay, so, hospitals are
short on these special masks,
but if they can't track them
down, what hope to I have?
Well, N95 masks aren't only for doctors.
Construction workers and
painters use them as well.
When it became clear
that the world was gonna
need lots of N95 masks,
people started scooping them up quickly,
thereby inflating the price
by a lot, like 700% a lot.
And while hospitals don't have the ability
to seek these masks out
and negotiate, I do.
Now this is very polarizing.
Yes, people should not be rewarded
for profiting off a crisis,
but desperate times call
for desperate measures,
and I desperately wanted to
protect my colleagues and I,
which brings us to day one.
Just, (beep) told me you
have 3M masks available?
- [Person On Phone] 3M
masks, the regular ones,
in the box with the 8210s, yes.
- What's the expiration
date on the N95 3M masks?
- [Person On Phone] 2021.
- All right, so they're good.
And the cost of the N95 mask?
- [Person On Phone] I think it was 7.50.
- Uh-huh.
And where are the masks?
- [Person On Phone] In New Jersey.
- Bear, are you coming?
Gimme five.
High five for masks.
High five for masks, come on, high five.
As it happened, Bear
knew something we didn't.
This day was not gonna go as planned.
(trap music)
Check out this truck that's
gonna deliver some masks.
20 feet of some horsepower,
that's gonna get us there safely,
and deliver these masks
to keep our doctors
and nurses healthy.
Someone scratched it.
(groans)
Let's do it.
Where're we gettin' the pick up from?
Yeah.
Where's the, where's the wipers,
there we go, oh high-quality wipers.
All right, we've arrived
where we're getting these masks from,
and I'm not gonna lie, it
feels really strange and shady.
Supposedly a car is gonna meet us here,
a truck is gonna meet us here.
- [Passenger] Yeah it must be these dudes.
- You think so?
- [Passenger] They're
goin' so slow through here.
(dramatic music)
- [Dr. Mike] Is this them?
I mean, this has to be them, no?
- [Passenger] What else would this be?
- They're wearing masks,
and there's three of them,
and they're, they have their hazards on.
We don't have a sign.
What's the sign?
(muffled speaking)
- [Passenger] This, (laughs)
this is, that's a quote
from every drug movie and TV show.
How do I know it's them?
You'll know.
Don't ask question.
- (laughing) You'll know.
- [Dr. Mike] Will they just come out
and start throwing masks?
It looks like they're
gonna make a right turn.
- [Person On Phone] Okay
so, he said any minute
you're gonna see a big, huge UPS truck.
Like you know, the color of a UPS truck.
- Okay.
- [Person On Phone] They're
gonna pull, pulling up.
So as it pulls up,
- Okay perfect.
- [Person On Phone]
you're already gonna see
the merchandise.
But he just called the,
- Awesome.
- [Person On Phone] he called the driver,
the driver said he's the next stop.
- Awesome, perfect, thank you.
All right, so it looks like
we have this quote unquote UPS truck
that's about to deliver these masks.
I don't know if it's
it, but I hope it's it,
'cause we've been waiting
here for a few hours now,
and I desperately wanna get these masks
to where they can be useful.
Welp, it pulled over, that's,
(laughs) not the thing.
Damn it.
Think this is the winner,
I don't think so 'cause
he's not slowing down.
(laughs) Damn it.
All right, so it's like hour
three, waiting for these masks.
I hope this is not a fiction,
fictional mask situation,
because I've already paid
$15,000 deposit to get them,
but we can't locate the truck driver.
It was in fact a fictional
mask situation, sort of.
The truck never showed up and another guy,
partner of initial guy,
showed up and informed us
that guy number one screwed
up the delivery date.
As it happens,
the shipment was due to
arrive the following day,
at a different location.
Anyway, they apologized profusely
and we made arrangements
to meet on day two.
I'm driving now to a fourth
location to get these masks,
and we're not gonna get the
full amount that we required,
but at least we're getting
some, fingers crossed,
I'm getting really frustrated
already at this point.
The goal is at least to get
half the masks today and then,
figure out what we're
doing the rest of the week,
but that will at least get
us through a couple of weeks
of testing.
(chimes music)
- Two hours later.
- All right, we got the masks!
Well at least half the
masks, and they look legit,
they're 3M, so I'm bringing
them to the warehouse right now.
Michael, does getting this
ease some of your strain
with ordering?
- Of course, everything
we can get our hands on
would help the situation,
but people need to understand
that these need to be reserved
for the medical community.
They are to prevent someone
from catching the virus,
who's dealing with a critical patient.
That's it.
- Hopefully we can get the rest tomorrow.
Hopefully, hopefully we
can get the rest tomorrow.
Oh, how naive I was.
I was playing right into
the hustler handbook.
They gave me half the merchandise
and a taste of success.
I was feeling good.
This thing was starting to turn around.
But all of this was just
priming me for the curve balls
that were to come on day three.
I just saw some doctors
performing tests on patients
just wearing surgical masks.
I saw nurses swabbing a patient's
nose, a famous influencer,
wearing a surgical mask.
This is putting them at risk.
We don't need to do that.
First of all, not everybody
needs to be tested,
at least right now,
because it's not that we're
gonna run out of testing kits,
the real issue is, the
safety of the providers,
meaning the nurses and
the doctors and the CMAs,
but then also, the environment.
If they're walking into an
office and they're sick,
they can be contaminating
everyone around them.
So it's not so much the
shortage of kits anymore,
it's more about getting the
personal protective equipment,
and figuring out the logistics
of how to conduct these tests.
Later today,
we're gonna be showing you
a drive-through testing site
that's being done right,
and they're gonna be using
some of the personal protective
equipment I'm buying.
So, I'm really excited
to show that to you guys,
but, on the journey now.
All right, we've arrived
at the location (laughs)
to get the masks.
And we're gonna take 'em directly
to the healthcare
providers that need them.
We already got a few offices
lined up, some drive-throughs,
hospitals, all of that,
(claps) let's make it happen.
As I walked into the warehouse,
discrepancies in pricing arose,
and I rushed to get guy
number one and guy number two
to talk it through.
Just to confirm and
replay back everything,
initially you and I discussed,
you told me the masks are 7.50 a piece.
I asked if you can do $7
a piece, you said yes.
Yesterday I paid 7.50 a
piece, which I don't care,
I paid the extra 50 cents, not a problem.
- [Mask Seller] Why 7.50?
You told me it was $6,
that's what I, what I wanted
to charge him, a dollar extra.
Why 7.50 now?
- [Person On Phone] It was
7.50, that was the price,
I told, I told you, I told you it was,
I told you maybe seven, I never said 7.50.
- [Dr. Mike] Honestly, I was
just no longer comfortable.
Luckily, the day prior,
I was able to buy $27,000 worth of masks,
so I jumped back in the van
and headed to one of the testing sites
where my first batch was already in use.
- Hi everybody,
I'm here today to walk you through
what it's like to come to a
drive-through testing site
to be tested for COVID-19.
I know a lot of people are very anxious,
and I know this is a very scary time,
but these are great sites to
help people get tested safely,
quickly, and securely,
and so we wanna alleviate any
sort of anxiety about this
and we're gonna walk you through
and drive you through
actually what it's like
for a real patient.
Patients come in if they
already have an appointment,
and they've already had the
order, so they've been screened
to make sure that they meet
the criteria that are set out
by the CDC, and the Department
of Health to get the test.
We're gonna have Dr. Mike keep
his windows up at all time.
Dr. Mike, with your windows up.
Are you scheduled to have
an appointment today?
I'm gonna make sure that
Dr. Mike is on our schedule.
Yes, you are, let's wave you through.
At this time, the
patient will be held here
until they make sure that
the nurse in the tent is free
to do the swab, and once they do,
they're gonna say Mike, Dr. Mike,
continue to keep your window up
until you get to the nurse
at the end of the tent.
Drive straight through
until the end of the tent.
The nurse will tell you
when it's time to roll down your window.
And at this point, the
patient will stop, the nurse
will put on her appropriate
personal protective equipment,
and give the instructions to the patient
to roll down the window
to have the swab done.
- Any recommendations for patients at home
who are maybe having mild symptoms?
Do they need to get tested?
Do asymptomatic patients get tested?
Do we have any guidelines on that?
- So unfortunately, right now,
given some of our constraints
like we just talked about,
patients who are healthy,
so they're not elderly,
they don't have any
underlying medical conditions,
and they feel well, they
can care for themselves
and they can eat and drink,
they're really not being
recommended to be tested
at this time.
For patients who do meet the criteria,
so anything above that,
of course we recommend
that they get tested, and
if they're critically ill,
of course that they go try
and get emergency services.
- As I just did a little
mock patient example here,
if I was to get the test done,
how long would I expect
to wait for the results?
- So at our testing facility,
the lab we're using takes
about three to four days
for the results to come back.
They are variable, there are some tests
which I know come back within a few hours,
some that take 24 to 48, and
some that take three to four,
and some that take even longer,
so I think it ranges a
spectrum, but a few days.
- All right, this is why
we did this entire journey,
to get personal protection equipment
for those who are on the front lines,
individuals who're gonna
be working a testing site
just like this.
People need to get tested,
but doctors, nurses,
all health professionals
need to be protected.
That's why I went on this
journey to get these N95 masks.
Sites like this are gonna be using them,
hospitals are gonna be using them,
medical offices are gonna be using them.
COVID-19, alert not anxious.
Alert not anxious doesn't just mean alert
with the news reports and information
that's being put out by the CDC, the WHO,
it means also being alert to
what your body symptoms are.
So if you start getting
worsening symptoms,
please contact a healthcare provider
before going to the office,
before going to the ER,
so they can guide you on
how to not get people sick
that are around you.
If you have any medical
supplies, or anything
that you think could be
used as medical supplies,
contact your local hospital,
see if they can be of help.
Because those supplies
are truly truly in demand,
and we need them now more than ever.
And please, stop buying
masks for personal use.
I put together a couple playlists for you,
here and here, check 'em out.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(trap music)